je joue steve rogers très court très
maigre beaucoup de maux et il ne veut rien de
plus que servir son pays et faire
ce qui est juste et il a été rejeté de
l'armée un certain nombre de fois donne-moi juste
une chance désolé fils
tu sauves ta vie
il ne s'agit pas de la transformation, nous avons
réfléchi très longtemps à la façon dont
vous faites la transformation d'une manière qui
n'a pas été vue auparavant et chaque fois que
vous pensez à tous les films qui l'ont
fait auparavant et donc plutôt qu'il
s'agit de la  transformation ce que nous avons
décidé qu'il s'agirait davantage d'
établir le personnage à l'avance,
il s'agit vraiment de l'homme qui entre dans
la nacelle, puis de l'homme qui sort
de la nacelle et c'est ce qu'est le rythme
dans le film plutôt que d'être et
maintenant, nous voyons ses muscles se gonfler et vous
savez, développez tout ce
qu'il a choisi par ce docteur dr erskine
pour cette expérience
qui fait de lui le capitaine américain, pas
n'importe qui peut obtenir cette procédure et obtenir des
super pouvoirs et être  un super-héros ce n'est
pas du tout le cas c'est steve rogers le
professeur erskine est presque une
figure paternelle pour steve voit quelque chose en
lui et finit par choisir steve pour être
la première personne pour l'opération renaissance
programme de super soldat la procédure
fonctionne il y a une attaque sur le  base peu
de temps après, toute la science est perdue
et steve reste le seul super soldat
qui ait jamais existé, il y a un problème commun à
tous les héros de merveille,
c'est qu'ils ont un côté très vulnérable
et
steve rogers ne fait certainement pas exception
à cela  il est probablement le plus
vulnérable
je joue peggy carter qui est un agent
et elle rencontre steve rogers elle
développe une sorte de relation passionnante tendue
avec lui qui consiste
à encourager et à soutenir son
voyage en
devenant capitaine américain le premier
vengeur entre peggy et steve  Rogers,
vous avez ceci, il y a une
compréhension mutuelle quelque part et je pense que
Peggy se rapporte à quelqu'un qui se bat vraiment
pour ce qu'il est  croire et
avoir vraiment à lutter tout le temps pour faire ses
preuves et elle étant la seule femme
dans cet environnement sait exactement ce
que cela fait que pensez-vous que
je pense que cela fonctionne
je pense qu'il y a une grande chose à propos du
fait qu'il a été choisi étant donné  ceci, vous
savez, beaucoup de super-héros sont soit
nés avec leurs capacités,
soit ils les obtiennent par accident, c'était un
gars normal qui a vécu la majorité de sa
vie en se battant et en se battant et
euh vous savez toujours en quelque sorte obtenir le
bout court du bâton
et ce genre de bonne fortune lui
est arrivé et je pense que c'est
quelque chose que tout le monde
souhaite secrètement qu'il
leur arrive